a lot of folks going out of town you  need to remember your empty house could  be a target for thieves metro police say  anyone could be a target  when it comes to property burglary a lot  of times it's you know people looking  for for opportunity the best way to  prevent burglaries and crime in your  neighborhood is to have an aware  neighborhood  so you could take some precautions when  you head out of town make sure your  house looks lived in ask your neighbors  to keep an eye on your property don't  post online that you're going on  vacation and if your house does get  robbed turn over any surveillance video  that you may have and don't touch any  places where there might be fingerprints  so police can do their invest